reed-solomon Forex Ibiza so I'm gonna be
talking about deep-fry which stands for
something unlike many of the other type
of thing and it's ultimately about some
interesting questions about polynomials
so so the set up so I'm going to say
very very little about stocks which is
another form of sub linear time proving
the main ingredient of stocks is a
certain protocol in in the original
stock there is a certain protocol called
the fry protocol which stands for
something which we will see soon and
I'll i'm gonna recap what that protocol
is at some point I will say things I'll
describe what the protocol is I'll
describe a new optimal analysis of this
protocol and then I'll finally talk
about what deep fry so deep fry is a
deep version of fry and deep stands for
something
okay it has mean good so few slides on
what the setting is the setting is IO
PPS Interactive Oracle proofs of
proximity okay so and the setting is for
sublinear time proof verification
there's a verifier who has access to
some string F it that's a long string F
the verify hasn't even read the whole
string just gets to poke it at a few
places and approver tries to convince
the verifier that F has some property
okay so the welfare ask questions of the
proven the prover replies the prove it
can reply either by just giving an
answer or the prover can also reply by
writing down another string which the
verify can then ask look at in certain
locations so and and then in this
there's some prove a time there's a
verifier time and there's the total
length of all the proofs written down by
the proven and these are all quantities
of interest that we want to minimize
so in picture this approval is verified
is a common string F we count the number
of accesses of the verifier into F and
that it is by allowing that that we can
hope for a verify that runs in sublinear
time it's
some questions the prove it responds
with some answers to some questions some
answers etc and the verifier gets to
poke any of these FIS and read
individual locations okay and do we have
two requirements for this the
completeness and the soundness the sound
is the completeness is that the web has
the property the prover should be able
to convince the verify that to accept
with probability one since we're in the
sub linear time setting you cannot hope
to be dead sure that F has the property
if F doesn't have the property but it's
very very close to having the property
then you must end up accepting that with
reasonable property so this is
inevitable just because we're working
with sub linear time so the best
soundness we can hope for is that if F
is Delta far from the property then the
prover cannot convince the verifier to
accept with I probably so this is a this
is a in a completeness case for F with
the property we won't accept with
property one for F in that soundness
case FF is Delta far from the
probability of a property we want to
reject with high probability okay so
that's the set up so sub linear time in
the input string which was that's long
string F that's right the running time
so linear time is sublinear than input
string that's yeah that's it yeah good
so for this so for this problem there
are many there's a very long history
which is covered very well in the whole
workshop so I'm not going to say much
I'm just going to talk about one
particular thing this is the start
protocol by BBH I've been setting it off
and it amongst all the many protocols
described in this workshop the claim to
fame of Stax is that they're practical
the first verification they have no
trusted setup and their post quantum I'm
not an expert on all these things
yeah but I'm but I know that this is the
claims to fame they claim to notoriety
of this is that it has large proofs
which okay this unfortunate but I mean
people are working on it as we speak and
and their two main ingredients two
stacks
one is encoding computations using
univariate polynomials and the second
aspect is verification of polynomial it
and so I'm not going to talk much about
the first aspect at all I'm only going
to put up for the second one which is
the verification of polynomial yeah so I
should mention that timing many recent
works in this area in coding competition
univariate polynomials was was was a big
step because in a lot of the classical
PCP stuff multivariate polynomials was
where all the action was and you even
daring to think you could do some real
univariate is quite it's quite new
because the univariate polymers are
inherently very non-local so it it was
brave that things could happen this way
and it it's quite interesting so what
I'm going to talk about is IO PPS for
the prop for the property of being a low
degree polynomial have a string I want
to know is it a low degree polynomial or
is it far away from being low degree so
this is the setting we have a finite
field F of size Q we have an evaluation
domain D which is of size n and need not
be the same as Q and we have access to
some function f from d2 q there D to F Q
and we have helped from approval and we
want to know is this close to univariate
polynomial of degree without help from
approval you have no chance because if
you just make a small number of queries
into the domain D it's consistent with
some univariate polynomial no as long as
the number of queries you make is less
than the degree there's some univariate
polynomials
what you see so they have the prover is
essential in this model yes that's
okay and so if if f is a polynomial
degree less than Rho and we accept if F
is far from polynomials of degree less
than ruin be region and Rho is going to
be a parameter which we think of as a
constant
maybe 0.1
okay so there's so there is a protocol
given for this problem by BBH ah it is
called the FRA protocol it built on
system slightly earlier works also in
the late tens so it's a very elegant
fast protocol for this my goal is to
describe the I will describe this
protocol completely and its properties
are the following
it has Oh an order and prove a work
order and proof size order log and
verify a time an order log inquiries
with order log in rounds and with all
constants are extremely small time is
Field Operations that's right and you
and you say order and prove our work
that's a bit fishy you're talking about
polynomials of degree and isn't there in
FFT involved but yeah but the answer to
that is it's order and provoke after you
after F has already been computed so
once F has already been computed only
further work is only order n inevitably
in any stark or whatever proof system
you have the computation of the function
that's supposed to be the low degree
extension of something would have
involved in FFT where n log ins would
have gone on but at this stage it's only
your dress
I should mention so for this if you ask
for the same problem and you relax the
requirement of let's say elegant so it's
actually elegant too but it's a it's not
concrete so this is a result of a lay
and Nick and Arielle and which solves
exactly the same problem with much
better theoretical bounds it has order n
log and prover work but order and proofs
I still order poly log in verifier time
but only constant queries and two rounds
so this is really really impressive on
the on just raw parameters we have to be
yes because a very recent result by Iran
and no guarantee from a few days ago and
that's it
because of a quick quick
good and so this has a big Constance so
I'm now going to describe the fry
protocol okay let me also mention it's
open whether you can do linear proof
size in one run namely a pcp p4 for this
problem it is known how to do an N poly
log and proof size for this problem this
is by Benson Sudan this was a very
influential work it was the first time
univariate problems are really used it
is it lies underneath both results a
branching okay good so the main building
block of the Frye protocol is an
algebraic sketch I'm going to describe
it first in terms of properties and then
I'll tell you what it is okay so you're
given a function f defined on a domain D
and it also takes in a seed X and what
it outputs is a function defined on
another domain of half the size so it
looks a bit like an extractor takes in a
long function gives you a short function
and it has properties so now the
property is okay so it's local every
entry of F prime depends on just two
entries aware its degree respecting in
that if F is a flow degree so is that
prime if F is a degree row and this is
Rho times n over two this would still
the same fractional degree and it's also
and this is the most important part
which is makes it useful is fairness
preserving if F is far from low degree
polynomials so is f Prime and then
there's some quantitative in how far is
far and that's where the soundness
section happens so these are the
properties of algebraic sketch once you
have an algebraic sketch I can now
describe to you the the Frye protocol
very easily but okay but just to get a
sense of it let me tell you what's also
inside the algebraic sketch
so here is here it is I'm describing the
whole algebraic sketch it's it's quite
simple it's based on the same idea as I
go under into an FFT okay so this only
works when the domain B is a power size
of power of two and we make D sorry D is
the nth roots of unity where N is a
power of two good and
so first let me tell you what to do on
polynomials if F is genuinely
polynomials what you do is you break it
into the odd part and the even part this
gives you two polynomials G of T Square
and H of T Square G n H since they take
T Square as input are naturally defined
on the n over 2 or throats of unity
because you're already squaring
beforehand so G and H are naturally
defined on this domain D prime which is
no.2 roots immunity and you use X to
give right yeah so you use the seed X to
take a random linear combination of G n
H and this is the algebraic sketch of F
takes F and the seed X and it produces
this if the observation is that if F was
degree D then the algebraic sketch is
degree D over 2 that's clear you can
also make this definition for any
function f even if it's not a low degree
polynomial just by this formula at any
point if you want to evaluate at this
point you look at the two square roots
of view and compute F at these two
points and do some linear combinations
with X in one and so this is the father
this is the algebraic sketch of F with
input X and it's clear from this that
low degree polynomials go to low degree
polynomials
okay so now I'm telling you what the fry
protocol is given this algebraic sketch
you start with that there are two phases
there's the commit phase where the
proven has to write down a bunch of
things and then we're going to check
what he writes the verifier first picks
a random X zero and asks for the
algebraic sketch of f with respect to X
zero that's half the sense then we do it
again and we get F 2 and F 4 it's at F 3
etcetera and each one of them is half
the size of the previous one so these
all shrink and the total amount of proof
lengths written is
open good now the query phase to check
that what the prover wrote is actually
okay and yeah and so the observation was
that if you started with the low degree
polynomial with degree row row n this
would be row of n over 2 row times in a
row times n over 4 etc at some point you
would get a constant problem
degree 0 polynomial evaluated at a bunch
of points and you have to make sure that
they're all constant they be and that's
what we're hoping for a B now the query
phase the query phase has that I mean
it's almost obvious what we want to do
first we use the locality property to
check that each fi is consistent with
its fi minus one okay so you check you
check this consistent and finally you
check that the last one is constant and
this is the protocol there's some
subtleties in where you do the checking
but ok at this level of talk it's all it
all works ok now I'm going to give you a
sketch of the analysis and highlight the
main lemma that happens inside ok so the
analysis Oh fry is fast reed-solomon io
P P in fact my whole talk is the
efficient
so okay so if f was truly a low degree
polynomial it's clear you could have
done everything all the FIS would have
been low degree all the way through and
at the end you'd have got a constant all
the tests would pass the soundness is
okay suppose F was far from low degree
we have some fun as preservation right
so you now you want to show that the
protocol rejects with high probability
okay so then you take two cases did you
write all your f is honestly was Fi
truly the sketch of fi minus one if it
was then and fi minus one was far then
so is Fi
so if at every stage you can you stay
you wrote your sketches honestly then
you would have stayed for it at the very
end you'd be far from constant and you
don't cut it so the forest preservation
property is what I will discuss it's one
of the properties that we will prove
that's it and and if you had honestly
written all the sketches yeah okay then
we caught you and if you didn't write
the sketches honestly then you'd catch
out catch you in the local consistency
between Fi and a 5-1 but again there's
some there's some subtlety about where
exactly do the checking but anyway abbis
i level it just works okay
the security is all you could you could
make errors or different regions in
different levels and they could overall
the tort you could just make one over
log infraction errors at every level and
they could be all in disjoint part so
that by the end you've made yeah okay
and you can fix it I'm not saying that
no okay
so now I'll tell you what the theorem
about the soundness guarantee of fries
this is what this is what we prove yes I
forgot say this joint work with Lee or
Goldberg Le Bon's a son and Shivangi
Sarah the theorem is that okay if F is
Delta far from polynomials of degree Rho
n then whatever the prover does Frey
rejects with probability min of Delta
and some quantity if Rho is a small
number like 0.1 then this mean of delta
and whatever is just Delta and this is
the best you could hope for for this
previous the original analysis gave a
minimum of Delta and 1/4 so it wasn't
able to go into the high rejection
probability zone and the previous
analysis by with Ellie and Shivangi gave
1 minus Rho to the 1/4 using some other
method and finally and this is the sort
of came as a big shock to us that the 1
minus Rho to the 1/3 is necessary in
this so there isn't there is no tighter
bound for try and the the necessary is
in the sense that okay there are certain
settings where for infinitely many
values of Rho you can set up situations
where there is a proven strategy to
cheat
yeah so the one example so these
settings we only know how to produce in
fields of small characteristic and also
when the evaluation domain is the whole
field so if the evaluation domain is
just a subspace or a subgroup which is
incomparable to the size of the whole
field then these counter examples do not
survive and there could be a better fry
theorem for them for this specific
protocol and it's also for a slightly
more general problem with a specific
problem which
okay is it possibly for a random subset
then it's Delta like read them
so you're asking if you sure with a
random function is the rejection
probability full alright good
we don't even know how to define Fri
when the evaluation domain is yeah right
so in fact a very good question is how
do you do fry over a general domain here
we use some algebraic structure of the
domain how what would you do inside okay
and so the main action in the in this
analysis is is the forest preservation
lemma so I'm going to give a full proof
of that right now only five minutes okay
so our hypothesis we have functions U
and V such that u plus X V is Delta
close to polynomials for many choices of
X I I want to I wanted to show that of U
and V are both far
yeah right sorry write the algebraic
sketch is related to linear combinations
of functions random linear combinations
of functions so the heart of the
analysis of the algebraic sketch is this
lemma which is okay you have two
functions U and V and for many choices
of X U plus XV is close to polynomials
of low degree then U and V themselves
are close to polynomials are loaded
that's what the state
so hypothesis is this we have two
functions UV so that form any choice of
X u plus X which Delta close ok so let P
X be the polynomial close to u plus XV
so this is for some X's we have a px
for some X for those X's we also have a
set s X which is the set of coordinates
of agreement between px and u + XV and
note that the size of SX is at least 1
minus Delta this is our assumption ok so
the so the idea is to study triple
intersections of these sets SX so the
first observation is if you take three
random XY and Z from this collection of
X's their expected intersection size is
1 minus Delta cube times n each one has
size 1 1 is Delta the expected triple
intersection is 1 is Delta cubed and
the evaluation points with me that's a
yeah okay took a random triple
intersection and it has big size how big
well the way I set things up so remember
there was a min with row to the
one-third okay so it's such that we can
assume that this is always greater than
Rho plus Epsilon so every triple
intersection is big okay now the next
observation is that if the SX intersect
s Y intersect SZ is bigger than Rho n
then X px X py + Z P sorry y py + Z PZ a
collinear that's what the claim is to
see this first note that X u + XV y u +
yv + zu + Z vehicle in here that's by
definition almost these three points are
collinear and u + DV agrees with PZ and
many points you plus y v agrees with py
in many points and u + XV agrees with px
in many points how many points in all
these points huh well what do you mean
by collinear these are elements of fq to
the n plus 1
and then X comma P X is a vector 1 1
tangent larger so it's
so you plus XV is a vector yeah so yes
so this is not just in the 2d space this
is in n plus one dimensional space
these 3 are collinear just by definite
just by I mean we made them calling it
that clearly collinear these are also
pulling is what I'm showing this is
close to this this is close to this and
this is close to this and furthermore
the sets where the agreements happen is
this set which is as big as Rowan yeah
and since this set is bigger than row n
which is the size of an interpolating
set for polynomial of degree row n the
agreement is the collinearity on such a
big set implies the collinearity x' of
the polynomials themselves okay so that
is this is the most complicated slide of
the talk
okay so combining this so we now have
many triple intersections that are big
and whenever there's a big triple
intersection you have a collinear triple
this means that there's actually a big
set of X's for which XP X's are all
collinear with each other okay and so
that means px looks like Q plus XR for
polynomials Q and R for many different
X's and once you have this we can finish
it up we know that for many X's U plus
XV is close to Q plus XR rearranging you
minus Q is Delta close to x times R
minus V this happens for many X's when
can a vector be close to many scalings
of another vector
well the vectors basically have to be 0
most of the time and so that means u
minus Q is close to 0 r minus P is close
to 0 and also on the same set and this
implies something ok so that is that I'm
zooming head questions
I'm going to say a little bit about deep
fry so deep stands for domain extension
for eliminating written yeah ok yeah I'm
doing it in the contrapositive if for
many X is U plus XV is close you is
close to some polynomial and V is close
to some polynomial
okay so I'm not going to prove anything
about it maybe if I just convey the main
idea I'll be happy with that okay so
first okay what do you do with approval
when you have access to approve what do
you are what kind of questions do you
ask them do you ask them questions for
which you know the answer and you're
just checking if they're honest or do
you ask them questions for which you
don't know the answer and you just wait
to see if we can catch them in a
contradiction okay so so far what we did
in deep fry in fry was we just asked
them to give us a give us the algebraic
sketch any entry of the algebraic sketch
to verify can check themselves remember
that's how we do their local checks okay
so that's what we did in in the fry
protocol now in deep fry we're going to
ask questions for which we just couldn't
possibly check ourselves but we'll just
take the answer incorporated into our
view of the world and carry on
and at some point hope to catch the
prover so what we're going to do is
we're going to ask questions at the
verifier that doesn't know okay so what
could you ask so here is a question that
you could ask the pro you could say oh
you have a polynomial in mind tell me
the evaluation of it at this other point
which is outside be the the verify has
no way of checking that because that
involves a linear combination of be
different evaluations or Rho and
different evaluations from the domain
okay but we can take it and say okay
we'll take that into account and let's
carry on with the protocol so you just
ask for a little extra information and
take it into account so what we'll do is
we'll pick a Z from the big field FQ
and ask what is P Z for what you have a
polynomial evaluated at Z and if it was
truly a low degree follow me the prove
it has something to do and if not they
would just make something up and then
hopefully we'll catch them later go to
support so this is the tiny bit of
algebra that will enable it suppose the
Provo claim that P of Z is a then the
polynomial P of P minus a is divisible
by t minus Z so the ratio of those two
this is the polynomial division is a low
degree polynomial t minus a over t minus
e is a low degree program so now you had
access to this function f we can
incorporate the information the the
provers claim about P of Z into this F
we
create a new function f star which looks
like f star of y is f of y minus a over
Y minus Z and this ought to be a low
degree polynomial and if it's not so
suppose f star was if F was truly a
polynomial which didn't take the value a
at Z then this would be a horrible
polynomial here this would be a rational
function so it won't be a problem
it'll be a rational function and this is
extremely far from all low degree
polynomials so this is something we
should we should help us catch the
proven later okay so here is a fact if F
if you did this process then the
distance of f star from degree B minus
one polynomials you had a function f and
you did this process then distance of F
star from degree B minus one problem is
exactly the same as the distance of F
from degree B polynomials consistent
with the claim okay so the prove of
making the claim and then you modifying
your function and working with that is
the same as weeding out all candidate
polynomials which are close to F which
don't which are not consistent to the
claim so we're really believing that
claim okay so now the high-level
structure of the protocol is something I
can race through it it's yeah so you
start with that you ask you pick a
random zi outside the domain you ask for
the claims or the values of f i on zi
okie you can ignore this because
incorporate this into your function f
that incorporation is something you can
do locally right the definition of this
modified function is just something you
can simulate yourself
given our calexis to air so we take this
new function and ask for the algebraic
sketch of that and continue that so
that's what the the new protocol is and
a query phrase is just to check local
consistency with everything so this is
exactly the same protocol except we also
asked along the way for claims about the
values of these f is outside and we
incorporated them into the function in
this division method and the soundness
theorem is that this improves from one
maestro to the one-third or one measure
to the one-half this one measure to the
one-half is a holy number it's the
johnson radius for list decoding
reed-solomon codes
but we don't know how to get into it
it's a very famous open question to
improve the listicle T of reed-solomon
codes up to radius 1 minus ro and if it
is true that you can listicle this with
polynomial list size up to radius 1
minus ro then the fact the ultimate
theorem happens so this would have been
min of delta and 1 minus ro but delta is
always less than 1 minus ro polynomials
a degree ro every functions within
distance Rho of 1 1 minus ro one of them
so so this would have been the ultimate
theorem we don't know how to do this
this is the famous open questions so if
that was true then we were to have the
ultimate analysis and if new finest
preservation mm maybe I don't have time
for that so okay it's a statement about
deterministic step no there was it was a
uniformly random Z picked outside okay
so I'll do it in one picture you made a
claim about some value outside this is
the picture there are many the prover
has many polynomials in mind this u plus
x2 is close to many polynomials it will
hedge depending on what the X is it may
it may go to closer to a different
problem it's nice to have many cool
polynomials close by but if you have pre
committed to what the value is at some Z
outside and it's a random Z then and
this is Z can be taken from a much
larger domain than what D is itself then
so degrees here are so small compared to
the size of this big domain so wherever
you claim a value you'd have to be
consistent with only one polynomial and
not many so you would only be able to
maintain one polynomial that's close to
your function as you cheat and when you
have only one polynomial to worry about
then it's much easier to do the analysis
and it's that some intuitive reason for
why committing to a value outside it
reduces your space for cheating
and one can imply the same method
improves the deep stock the stock
reduction from general computation to
polynomial ax T proving you can ask for
values outside the domain where your
function is committed to and yeah you
just ask for it and incorporate it into
whatever was written and it helps yeah
and some open questions which I just
leave them is the conjecture about the
sanity price is it no we don't know that
yeah
proper code like give values ethics -
you can consider rational functions
that's also a very good code but it
stops being linear and then I get things
get messy so I don't know if that's yeah
yeah so I should all say all these
llamas the tree I stated about fairness
preservation there's there are analogs
for general error correcting codes
depending only on the distance the
polynomials were a bit of a distraction
okay
[Applause]